okay guys we are live let's see if this
is working properly and I think it
should so welcome to a new show uh this
is a new YouTube live it's a special
occasion we have Black Friday going to
talk about about Black Friday but not
only we're going to talk about me
language learning now let me chat let me
chat check the chat and see if
everything is working
properly I cannot see the chat actually
but let's
see okay
so if you guys are around please just
write something like a I'm here I'm
alive Mo D says hello Luca I saw other
messages before but for whatever reason
they have disappeared but I took the
time to write one
question uh hi from Rome to Nicaragua CH
Teresa
yo uh branka hi Luka kolina hola
Luka hi to everybody
hell so let's get
started and we're GNA talk about
language learning so feel free to ask uh
any question this is called ask Luca
anything so you can ask me anything you
want um
a couple of question a couple of things
I wanted to tell you feel free to write
on the chat um if I don't see any of
your questions is
because um there's going to be a lot as
usual so I'm going to try to do my best
to answer everybody's question and let's
see what happens um I already saw a
couple of interesting um questions um
let's start with dude hi dude uh so will
the Liber practice help to overcome the
intermediate plateau and language
running for those who don't know know
about the infamous intermediate Plateau
well that's the Zone where you get stuck
you're kind of like a low intermediate
learner and you want to reach fluency
and you don't know what to do um and the
answer to dude is yes Del Liber practice
is one of the things that you have to do
in order to overcome the intermediate
plateau in other words if you do not do
things deliberately then you're going to
get stuck let me give you an example for
example you started reading something
you you read a lot but you're not doing
this deliberately you're just reading
for the sake of reading well doing it
deliberately means to highlight words to
underline stuff um to JW down words to
reuse them maybe in a conversation this
is just one example but the intermediate
the let's say the Liber practice can be
applied to any area of language rning so
the answer to dude is yes you need
deliberate practice and you also need
simple practice in order to reach the
upper Ence of language learning so to
speak hi Enrique hi to everybody I'm
seeing here a lot of questions um Dakota
asks what is deliberate practice um
dakot if you're interested you can just
type deliberate practice there's a book
that is amazing which is called science
the peak of something like that exper I
have it I have it somewhere there uh
it's by edicon uh and it should be
science or Peak the science of expertise
or something along the lines it talks
about how amazing chess players amazing
athletes amazing language learn reach
the upper echelons of whatever skill and
it's a really important skill and um you
know not a lot of people talk about this
in the in the realm of language learning
and it really makes a difference if you
really want to speak any language
well uh globos asks what is your
favorite language you've learned I love
them all it's like having children and
more and more children come to your
family you love them all but I have to
say that I fall in love with El Greek
and I try to learn it every single day
and I live actually with a Greek guy
from Thessaloniki who's probably
watching this very same show from the
other room uh and we have uh Mula so we
have a nice chat every day um you know
about the meaning of life geopolitics
and everything in between in Greek and
it makes me happy to be able to finally
use Greek after so many years of
learning um so did you learn Chinese
what will be your advice to learn that
language yes yes I learned Chinese back
in the day 10 years ago I I think I
started in
2010 and uh it was one of the most
amazing experiences unfortunately I do
not speak Chinese that often I I do not
use it that often these days um but um
it's great um it's just a fantastic
language to learn and very useful these
days I would just say that if you
started learning Chinese my advice is to
um learn the tones focus on
pronunciation and intonation first and
foremost and there is a good way of
learning um Chinese tones and the bad
way of learning Chinese tones the
traditional way of learning Chinese
tones doesn't work that much but if you
work in chunks so you start
learning instead of the single tones you
start learning pairs of tones for
example you know w means I sure means to
be but if you learn just as one sound
you don't have to make so many efforts
and try to learn every single syllable
and this is not how we learn you know
English Italian or any other language
imagine learning Italian English or any
European language just focusing on the
single syllable it would drive you nuts
so Ernie asks Ernie the daily learner I
think I've seen this uh I've seen you
Earnie before luga would you learn
Chinese again what would you do
differently wonderful question yes I
made a video about that about my failure
learning Japanese and I can't wait to go
back to learning Japanese but the next
language produ product product project
is actually learning
Turkish uh and that is going to start in
January and I'm seriously contemplating
the idea of doing some live shows or
just showing you how I learn from the
GetGo so you see what actually happens
here on my very same desktop when I
learn foreign languages ad Amo says Luca
just bought your two courses and book in
Black Friday they are amazing fantastic
Ramiro and by the way I'm going to say
this three times in the beginning now in
the middle and at the end we are
currently running a Black Friday
campaign and I'm just going going to um
put the link here you can see directly
all our products and what we're doing
right now so um I think some of you know
that I have a language learning school
or Academy and we have as of now I I
founded this company uh two years two
and a half years ago in 2021 we have um
so far four courses two in English to
completely in Spanish and they are about
how to learn any
language um the first one
is about how to learn any language from
scratch through my bad directional
translation method the second one is how
to overcome the intermediate plau the
very same Plateau I was talking about
before and then we have the very same
courses in Spanish and my book I
published this
ebook um three four months ago and it's
going really well um I'm super excited
about this this pro pro project in
general because people are you know
loving the book and it's a simple way of
getting into my langu running world I
tell stories of my life that I've never
talked about
before uh so thank you uh again for all
those who bought the courses if you want
to check um anyway what these courses
are about you can check on the link I'm
going to share it two more times during
this live we have 50% off every single
course and the book until Monday so uh
maybe after this live show just take a
look if you're interested and if you're
not that's that's great anyway uh if
you're if you can't afford the courses
or for whatever reason you're not
interested you can always um you know go
to the website look.com I'm just gonna
I'm gonna share this here and you can
sign up to the newsletter and the reason
why I'm saying this is because this new
newsletter is completely free and I'm
sending um every every single month
we're sending um by bi-weekly messages
and also one message every month about
something called that that happened
during the the Month people are loving
these stories of of my life of what
happened behind the scenes and we're
getting um for 2024 we're we're getting
um a lot of new stuff we are about to
publish a very cool completely free
ebook that is basically an entire book
that I wrote and it's an Audi book
completely free if you sign up to the
newsletter you're going to get that uh
very soon it's going to be ready within
the next three weeks I've been working
on it my team and I and um I promise
it's going to be great um I'm going up
just a second uh going up here to see if
I missed some questions uh again if I
miss some of your questions guys um
sorry about that it's just that there's
many questions and I'm gonna try to
answer each and every question in a
concise
way Dakota says say Granda hi from
California hi Dakota hi back I think D
you asked me the question about uh the
Del liberate
practice um so do you juggle several
languages G Doug says yes I do meaning
that I get to use six or seven languages
every single day and I think that the
secret of speaking a bunch of languages
is actually to use them if you can't use
them you're going to lose them as they
say so I'm trying to build a life around
languages so that I can get to use them
every single day um let me see here
David definitely looking forward to your
latest book to come out of Dutch We're
translating the book into Italian and
Spanish there's the next languages read
by me in a recording
studio um howdy lukino when will you
come to Berlin Richard calls me lukino
actually we were thinking of U making a
live Richard and I he was here in Rome
we had a lot of fun and if you guys are
interested by the way Richard for those
few left in the world who don't know
Richard simut in the realm of language
learning he's the king he speaks 50
languages one of the most amazing people
I've ever met not just a great polyot
but a fantastic person in general
finish language nuggets hi Luka how do
you do you social skills how do social
skills affect language learning what
principles do you follow in this big
question big question I know I I'll try
to answer in a very um in a very concise
way social skills are important so in
your life in general and language
learning too because they allow you to
um have smooth conversations it's not
about just the the amount of words that
you know or about the sentences that you
know about your grammar or your
pronunciation what really counts is what
you do with those words and what you do
with those sentences and I think that
when you when you're you know you learn
social skills then you also learn to be
a better conversationalist I don't know
if conversationalist is a word in
English but you get the point so uh
social skills are important and as any
other skill you can learn them you can
you can acquire skill you can read books
you can see how uh people inter interact
in real life but you can also for
example take courses watch YouTube
videos that talk about that there's
there's ways there there's a will
there's a way as they say so social
skills are important when it comes to
speaking language as
well ghost which language was the most
difficult for you to learn without a
doubt Japanese because I did not know
how to address that in the other
question before they asked me how would
you do it how would you address um
Japanese now the mistake that I made is
that I was using my B Direction
translation which always works but I was
not doing it with the right material so
I was trying to translate from the
get-go very long sentences and you don't
want to do that when it comes to
Japanese because the syntax is
completely different what what I would
do now is to get comprehensible input
input I can understand for example
bilingual texts in Japanese and in
English or in Italian and then get as
much comprehensible interesting and Rich
content as I can maybe for a couple
years enjoying the content in Japanese
and then I will start speaking with a
tutor this is what I would do in a
nutshell it's a little bit more
complicated than that but uh in a
natural um massive input is is the way
to go for me um let's
see um which language was the most
difficult to learn I've WR that c how to
remember new words I'm learning
hystology and I wonder what's the best
way to remember complicated terminology
that's a big question about learning
vocabulary um how do I answer this in a
very concise way learning vocabulary is
the question you know uh that people ask
me all the time and I always say that
the most important thing again is to get
massive input why because as your
language as your language skills evolve
you're going to build um a growing
infrastructure linguistic infrastructure
in your brain and the more words you
know the more sentences you know the
more exposure you have to your target
language the more connections you will
have so words that do not stick now will
stick later you will recog recognize
certain parts of like in in root in the
root of words you will recognize some
other words and you will start learning
them um they will stick they will stick
U more but also in answer to your
question I would say highlight words is
something that works if you highlight
highlight certain words and you focus on
just the words that you find interesting
not every single word that you do not
know otherwise it's there's too much and
your brain is going to go whoa stop wait
a second is this is too much
and lastly I would read a lot like
reading as much as you can this is going
to make a huge difference reading as
much as you can sorry if you heard this
what's up is because I have what's up
open so I'm just going to turn this off
I have a lot of things open here
WhatsApp Skype etc
etc so um let's see will you will you
continue learning languages um forever
well yes I will I will continue learning
languages I I I don't think that I have
a number 20 30 40 I will I think I will
continue learning languages one after
the other until the rest of my life
because uh my family in particular um my
father but also my grandmother my family
in general is stop me the value of
learning new things and every single
language that you learn expands your
world so I don't think I'll ever stop
learning languages I would like to learn
the piano and get into music too but
let's see what
happens uh greetings from uh Iraq hi
Karim how's your Hungarian learning
process um doing going I'd love to see
an update video about it um I want to
record a cool video spoiler alert with
my tutor Petra with whom I have day not
daily but weekly conversations and it's
a special video it's not just a simple
conversation uh but I will break down
the process of actually U talking to p i
I will do with multiple languages so 20
24 is going to be the year where I I
hopefully cross in fingers I'm going to
go back to making um weekly videos on
YouTube showing more you know not just
talking about language writing in
general but showing more what I do on my
desktop with my tutors and if you guys
like it I can always uh you know also
shoot videos out when I'm out and about
talking to
people um once your Tak on Richard is
Raising multilingual children well he's
he's raised
uh one well he's I think his his child
his his daughter is 16 right now we
talked about him multiple times um I
think I don't know the nuts and bolts
and the details of his philosophy of his
take uh when it comes to raising M
lingual children but in a nutshell we we
talked a little bit about it but I think
he gave a wonderful gift to his daughter
the ability of speaking multiple
languages she's going to have that for
the rest of her life so I think that's
that's great there's multiple ways of
raising a child in a mult
lingual environment so to speak
bilingual or even three or four
languages there's a lot of fascinating
books if you if you write for example
how to raise a bilingual you know how to
raise bilingual children you'll kind of
get a delus of interesting books about I
have a I have a couple
here
um so let me see let me
see
um someone asks in
Russian one is one is the next podcast
with David is going to happen we're
going to do a live in February and we're
gonna well I spoiler alert we're going
to do something special which is not
just having a conversation in multiple
languages but um we're going to do an
analysis of an Italian text for those
who were interested in Italian and to
show how to to build the skills of
actually um dissecting a text because
that's the very first skill when you
have a text in a foreign language how do
you understand it uh having
your own another text uh the same text
in your own native language or in
English that's going to be an
interesting
video
um authentic asks uh your bilateral
translation by Direction translation
method is just another way of doing
flash cards isn't it not exactly I would
I wouldn't I wouldn't say that I made a
video about flash cards the B
translation is is a method where you
basically dissect entire units of
language in this case dialogue the
dialog and then you attack them from
multiple angles you do some recall but
actually um it's not about recalling
it's not about remembering it's about
understanding when you're I use the B
Direction transl translation method to
start learning any language for the very
first three months so in that phase a
lot of people think oh I have to learn
you know just started learning Swedish
German Japanese I have to remember words
I have to remember every single word etc
etc that's not the point when you're a
beginner you don't have to remember
anything everything is difficult to
remember because you do not have the
linguistic infrastructure in place the
main point hear me out this is a very
important Point as a beginner it's to
understand the structure of the language
not to memorize it it's going to be much
easier down the line down the line to
memorize things when you have enough
exposure to the language so the B
Direction translation in this regard is
completely different from flashcards
it's a holistic way of understanding the
basic um Foundation the basic structure
of a language and to recall in order to
understand not in order to remember it's
a very important
Point uh Fran Chalo I'm interested if I
can't buy before Thursday night next
time that's fine it's not the end of the
world we're going to run other other
campaigns is the methodology of learning
different for methodology of
learning that language is different than
modern languages I guess um no it's
exactly the same it's just that we've
been taught to learn thatb languages in
a very traditional way I had uh I think
for whatever reason it's not public
anymore or you might find it on my blog
there's a very long post about how to
learn that languages the Modern Way the
non-traditional way it's you can apply
the B directional translation or any
modern uh method in order to learn dead
languages there's no difference the fact
that their dead languages we consider
them dead makes us think that we have to
just read them but you can speak them
you can listen listen to them you can
find audio these days and even speakers
even people who say hey let's speak
Latin let's speak Greek you know ancient
Greek so you can learn that languages in
a completely different
way um so how do you know this
comprehensible input is working I know
that it's working with with a a simple
experiment for example you consume let's
say that you consume podcasts right you
consume one podcast um today and then
then you check two months later you
listen to the same podcast maybe at the
first time just by listening to it you
understood you understood 30% without a
transcript now you understand 50% this
is how you see that um you know
comprehensible input works compreh
comprehensible input is the main pillar
of learning any language because it's
about language acquisition there's a big
difference between acquiring a language
and learning a language and actually you
can acquire and learn a language at the
same time it's it's a little bit
complex now to go into the nuts and
bolts and you know the ins and outs of
acquiring versus learning but I can
guarantee you that comprehensible input
is the way to go about language learning
there's a lot of methods but this is a
principle the more exposure you get to
your foreign language the better it is
and then on top of that you can speak
you can use it you can write it but
there is no way way around it if you can
just try to speak that language and you
don't get a lot of um inputs um well
that's that's going to stole that's
exactly what happened with me with
Hungarian I tell the story in my book
that I got completely stuck after two
years of learning Hungarian I could have
and I could still have a nice
conversation about pretty much anything
in Hungarian but at the time I could
have this very nice conversation with my
tutor I was completely lost when it came
to uh listening to even podcast for
intermediate Learners and so I just told
myself this is not working what do I
have to do instead of just having
conversations with my tutor and I told
myself okay let's try to go through some
podcasts and you know and for example Cy
Hungarian with Cy for those who are
learning Hungarian she's fantastic and
also Petra my um Hungarian tutor and
teacher she has a wonderful website too
easy Hungarian it's called I listen to a
lot of these podcasts for people like
let's say A2 B1 and my Hungarian
comprehension skyrocketed together with
the other skills so uh let me see here
there's a lot of question questions
um I'm good uh you can ask questions in
different language languages but I will
reply in English just because uh again
we we we want to keep it monolingual but
one day if you like it we can do maybe a
bilingual live Italian English English
French whatever language you
want um
Luka very interesting question so for
example she uh Brian asks um should I
learn another Lang can I learn another
language if I have a B1 in English so
can I can I start learning suo which
means Swedish and the answer is I would
say yes um Brian I would rather get to a
B2 level in English because in that way
you're going to transition between
language learner and language user
there's a big difference a language
learner learner has to sit down and
still listen to podcasts and still use
transcriptions in order to understand so
you're just a learner you're a kind of a
student and you still have to sit but
when you become a language user and you
get to a B2 level then you can use that
language you can integrate it into your
life for example uh when you go running
you can listen to a podcast in English
or you can have a conversation with your
friends you can watch a Netflix show and
at the same time that's the moment where
you can add another language because in
this way you are learning technical two
languages you have to cope with two
languages but one is already part of
your life that's that would be my advice
but if you want to learn Swedish you
have this uh burning desire to start
learning Swedish you have to remember
that then you have to learn two
languages at the same time so since in
English you still have a B1 and you have
to engage in deliberate practice well
that's a moment where you have to
dedicate you know every single day time
to English and time to Swedish and that
is taxing that takes a lot of energy and
time because you're dealing with two
languages not just
one
um which means do you speak often in
Polish and the answer is a resounding
yes I speak mov uh every day let's let's
switch back to English otherwise people
don't understand uh I I speak Polish
pretty much every single day I listen to
I read Gazeta which is um a newspaper
polish newspaper I watch t n 24 which is
a YouTube channel I I watch makovich I
don't know if you anybody knows makovich
but he's a very interesting character
who has a fantastic YouTube videos about
history um you know about traveling uh
so I get to use uh polish every single
day I'm a language user in that case
because I think I have a solid B2 um so
the answer is
yes me um let me see here uh oh boy this
is a very long
uh it's just going up and down uh let me
see
um let me see
here he's asking me when I'm gonna am I
going to launch a course in in in
Brazilian Portuguese for now uh we still
know we're still building the courses
mainly in English and Spanish and then
as the as the the the academy grows
we're going to translate that into
multiple languages the courses we have
uh in particular the BDT the B
neutralization method has subtitles in
um in Brazilian
Portuguese Kim asks do you think chipd
and its likes will Revol revolutionize
language learning the answer is yes um I
think fundamentally no in the sense that
we're human beings we still have to talk
to other people we have to use the
language we have to absorb it we have to
get exposure to life to the way language
is really spoken by human beings but you
can
um optimize the process and you have
other tools um you can add other tools
to your toolbox in order to learn
languages so there's a lot of fantastic
um ways in which you can use catchup PT
and any artificial Intel AI tool at your
disposal nowadays for example one way in
which you can um let's say optimize the
process of speaking is talking to a
machine I know it's not this exactly the
same thing but it's still practice if
you really imagine that the the person
you're the the the machine you're
talking to as a person you can start
talking to that person and the huge
Advantage is that the machine does not
judge so you will not feel judged and
you feel a little bit more relaxed
because talking to people can be taxing
when it comes to um you know in general
interacting with other human beings
because we're all self-conscious when it
comes to learning a foreign language we
still do not speak it well we're full of
doubts I was in Greece this year I uh
talk about this I talked about this in
the last monthly email that we sent
through the newsletter and I talked
about the fact that even if I've been
listening to Greek for five years I've
been learning Greek for five years and I
think I speak it decently now I think
I'm I'm decently
fluent uh the problem is that um I was
going through certain situations for the
first time because that was the very
first time I was in Greece speaking
Greek I had been to Greece before but
never speaking Greek and uh going to the
supermarket ordering something at the
restaurant was new for me old and new at
the same time old because I had done it
before in another language is new
because they never done it in in Greek
so using interacting using the language
whether human beings um is emotionally
taxing and speaking with a machine is
the that gray area that you say okay
well I'm a little bit self-conscious now
let me talk to the machine and just
practice practice practice then you
start using it with other people in real
life and the all those hours spent
talking to the machine will definitely
helps this is one of the many ways in
which Chad GPT and any other AI tools
going of revolutionize the way you learn
languages
um Globus s difficult to pronounce would
talking to yourself in a language do the
same effect as practicing with natives I
was just talking about this uh just just
uh just now it's not the same thing
because when you speak with other people
you get all this emotional stuff right I
I don't know raise your hands like
virtually those who have experienced
this um feeling of self-consciousness oh
gosh is he going to understand me and am
I going to understand this guy or
someone asks you point blank something
and you go like I don't understand what
do I do do I reply do I reply something
anything and don't look like a fool or I
do I just say I do not understand and
most of us just decide to not just
pretend that we understand because we're
self-conscious we feel stupid we feel
judged this comes from school but the
reality is that any native speaker who's
a nice guy or nice girl will appreciate
the fact that you're trying to speak um
their their native language it's
everything here the fears that we have
everybody goes through that because
everybody went through the school system
and we were thinking more about the
performance than the active
communication and think about that
children are much better language
Learners not because you know yes their
brain is more plastic and everything
else but just because they don't care
they don't care when they speak their
own native language they just want to
FOC they just focus naturally on
communication well as adults we focus on
performance did they get that right did
I conjugate that verb right who cares
this is a short experiment if I say for
example something along the lines of
let's say that I've been learning
English for some time right for three
months and um and I let go of all this
Paradigm oh I have to perform I have to
speak uh perfectly I have to conjugate
every verb perfectly and you go uh and
you try to say whatever comes to your
mind tell me if you understand this let
me
say yesterday meet friends do you
understand what I wanted to say I'm
pretty sure you did did and if you if
the the message got through yes the
grammar was not perfect but you got the
message and then someone corrects you
can correct you if you're talking to a
tutor so if the the tutor or anybody
corrects you it means they got the point
at the end of the day here's here's why
vocabulary is more important than
grammar especially at the beginning but
you know speaking is a is a big thing
it's not just the technical stuff it's
not just the social skills it's also the
emotional stuff because language
learning at the end of the day is an
emotional Adventure it's not just about
words grammar Etc it's emotional
remember that so let me see here um
again guys sorry if I skip some of the
questions maybe you can ask them again
one more time uh so that I try to get to
answer almost every question I think
it's not gonna happen but let's try um
do you have any experience in Finnish
I'm gonna Dakota asks I'm gonna meet too
who's a Finnish Finnish friend uh
tonight we're going to have dinner
together I have some indirect experience
with Finnish um I was in Finland once
it's a fascinating language one day I
will learn it um and yes how was your
experience with your Hungarian last time
you visited Budapest it was great uh and
one episode in particular I remember
actually two are the taxi going from the
airport to the center and from the
center to the airport and I was talking
to the taxi driver the first one was
this uh moros the word moros means
grumpy guy uh in the 60s who did not
speak a word of uh of Hungarian I had to
explain everything in Hungarian where we
wanted to go Etc and then I had to get a
receipt for my company for the taxi for
the taxi ride and I was proud that I
managed to do that I was somewhere was
some technical stuff you know you know
the vat and everything in between but I
managed to communicate um rather well
and I was proud of the fact that I
managed to speak with someone who did
not speak a word of English and neither
did he want to speak a word of English
so uh that was a fascinating experience
and going to the airport um sorry and
when I went went to the airport when I
had to get back to Rome I spoke for 30
minutes straight just in Hungarian with
a very nice guy he spoke English too we
spoke a little bit of English but he
preferred speaking Hungarian we had a
fantastic time the language was just
flowing why because I was focusing on uh
on communication I I got this amazing
feeling that I got also the previous
year when I was talking to Petra my
Hungarian teacher whom I met in Budapest
also last year where I did not care
about grammar I didn't not care about
translating I was translating in my head
no I was just communicating if I did not
know a word I would just circumvent it
try to use some other word and the
amazing thing is that when you focus on
communication you get to use what you
know in order to get the point across so
the conversation was very smooth we
talked about everything like from you
know how Budapest was back in the 70s we
talked about whether Budapest is
dangerous or not talked about everything
it was just an amazing experience so um
and I come back with stars in my eyes
and thinking Hungarian is amazing I want
to go back one day I would like to live
in Budapest this is one of my uh
projects for at least three months it's
an amazing City if you've never been you
should um let me see here
[Music]
um let me go up because the you know the
the chat is going crazy um have you ever
taking any language exam at C2 level how
do you prepare for that exam especially
in the listening part I have I just
found it's somewhere there I think yeah
it's it's there the the the the C2
certificat in in German I got it in
20110 I have the C2 I pass the C2 in
English French Spanish and German I'd
like to do the C1 in Polish and the C1
in Russian so I did pass these four
exams it's difficult for the listening
part I would say uh Raj I think you
asked this question first get a lot of
input you will get to hear this from me
a lot listen Listen to As much as you
can the more you listen the better but
you have to listen to stuff that is
interesting and that you can at least
partially understand by at least I mean
60% because if you listen to stuff that
is too too difficult you're just going
to get discouraged there's this amazing
uh Concept in um in skill development
which is called the Goldilocks zone or
the zone of proximal development you can
look it up on on Wikipedia and basically
it's a Zone where something is not too
easy and and not too difficult if it's
too easy it's too easy you don't learn
much and you get bored while if it's too
difficult it's discouraging you have to
learn to find yourself in that zone
where a task any task regarding language
learning is not too easy and not too
difficult is just a little bit above
your level so if you're listening to a
podcast just to give an example if you
can understand at least
60% then that's great but if you're
listening to something you do not
understand at all that's a bad thing so
my my piece of advice in regard to your
question is listen a lot that's the base
of the pyramid so to speak and then on
top of that get ready for the exam
because we're going to ask you specific
questions or some listening tasks that
you're going to perform within that exam
that that is very special and even
native speakers will find it difficult
if they don't prepare but again going
back to your question listen to your
target language as much as you
can so let me see here
um uh once we achieve a good level in
the target language in live in country
having limited time for dedicated study
is passive learning on the daily life
enough to keep improving or not any
exposure any meaningful exposure to the
language is a chance to learn so yes my
answer is yes if you get the chance of
watching a Netflix show um YouTube
videos to chat on and off with some
friends that you go out with uh then you
will keep improving of course you going
to get faster if you engage in
deliberate practice on top of the your
exposure to language so in other words
using the language every
day um have you ever seriously senten
mind authentic says says to the point of
keeping a track of how many thousand
sentences you've mind do you think the
native speakers count Words do they
think about the amount of words they
they know we got this Obsession about
numbers because there're safety numbers
as they say right they say well if I can
count if I can measure something then I
feel safe then I feel like I'm making
progress now to do your point I had this
next to me so when it comes to sentence
mining I don't count the sentences but I
do JW down let me give you an example I
hope you can see it I'm not sure maybe
the camera is not working that properly
but it looks that it's visible the
problem is not the camera quality the
pro the problem is my handwriting it's
terrible anyway just to give an idea
this
is um a notebook which is called
conversations with Sophia she's my Greek
tutor and basically when we have
conversations what I do let me let me
just show you we have conversations and
I jut down something which is called
episodic memory framework and this means
that I write for example here it's
lesson two with Sophia emotions and
language learning speaking on language
learning of course um and this gives you
the context in which these sentences
were like I mind sentences to use your
own uh your your own terminology which
means that I was listening I was Rel
listening to the lesson I had and I was
just jotting down the words that I found
per you know meaningful and then um I
don't think about the amount of words or
amount of sentences I don't I don't
think in these terms I think in terms of
quality of communication so for example
two weeks later I do this once a week I
just take these sentences and I just
rehearse the conversation because these
sentences are dense enough so they can
remember exactly what I talked about and
I just can talk to myself so it's not
about amassing hoarding like I'm not a
word hoarder uh I I I just make sure
that I write sentences I jot them down
while I relisten to the lesson because I
find these interesting and I always
write sentences or chunks of sentences
just to give an idea
here
um like the the further it is the the
better just just to give you an idea
this is just one snippet or snippet or
traffic is bad in Athens you know uh or
other other Snippets of Snippets of
really chunks it's not even word it's
not even sentences it's just chunks that
I can reuse and by the way in the
academy we are about to release an
amazing speaking course for A2 Learners
not B1 B1 that's later but for those who
want to learn how to use uh chunks and
and and form sentences for um amazing
and effective communication remember
it's not about counting words it's about
making words count and using words for
Meaningful
communication so uh let me
see says Taylor Swift is the music is
the music industry Lucas the language
industry hugs from Cheetah thank you
compared to Taylor Swift what what an
honor um
so milun if you had to how would you
take old an old listening approach I
have no problem to spend more time
learning the language I'm not sure what
you mean by have no no problem to spend
more time learning the language but my
answer to the how would you take an old
listening approach is what I said before
listen to stuff as much as you can to
anything that is interesting rich and
slightly challenging for you the more
the
better asks and like how many
um subjects topics can you talk about in
in MA in Hungarian the answer is I can
talk about anything you can talk about
anything in a simple way so again don't
think about in how many topics it
doesn't matter how many topics what
matters is the skill to address any
topic that's a different matter it's not
quantity it's quality so I invite you
all to stop thinking to get rid of to
snap out of this mindset of how many
words do I know how many grammar rules
how many topics because it doesn't
matter it it doesn't work this way in
language learning Even in our own native
language we can talk about certain
topics and for example if I have to talk
about rocket science I'm G to be
completely lost in Italian whether it's
Italian or any other language because
this is a this is um a topic I simply
don't know but I can talk about the
little I know with the skills I have
remember this is really
important
um beak asks very
interesting do you remember some Eureka
moments in the languages that you
have
beash beash is a nice uh it's a nice
term saying to um um dominat it's coming
in in all the languages except in
English to master a language there's no
such thing as mastering a language first
it's important to stress but yes I did
didn't have some eure moments the last
one was in Greek uh for in Greece for
Greek when I got to use the language and
uh or in Hungarian last year when I for
example had um this amazing conversation
with Petra because normally when we have
conversations uh on on Skype or on Zoom
I struggle a little bit because I focus
on performance we are in this
environment Zoom teacher performance but
when I was there in the environment with
her and we were not having a lesson we
were focusing on communication was a
different matter completely different
and so the the answer is yes I had many
of these uh and um that's either when I
start understanding everything and you
go like wow I understand a movie that's
so cool or when you manage to have a
meaningful communication with with with
someone without without a a problem you
know uh that's that really makes a
difference and it it really motivates
you these like progress however small is
uh is motivating you know that's that's
that's a very important point in
language
learning are you going to the language
event in panang South Malaysia December
unfortunately no Richard was here in
this very same apartment 4 days ago he
was talking talking to me about it he's
flying there but I will be at the polyga
conference sorry polyga gathering in
Prague in May you can look it up poly
Gathering Prague May and I hope to see
you
there uh let's see retired and happy
what's your opinion I like I like the
title like I like the name I want to get
retired and happy too what's your
opinion of news and slow Spanish as a
source of input I don't have a lot of
experience with that but I can tell you
that if you like it and if you find it
compreh
and slightly above your level that's
that's that's what you need um Eddie
ask it's language learning so I'm
addressing questions what's what's the
what's the topic today's topic it's it's
anything connected and related to
language
learning um so uh another ad here I
promised I would talk to you about this
one more time and I will share I would
share the the link so we're running a
Black Friday campaign with all the
courses all the stuff I'm telling you is
inside the courses whether it's for
beginners or for intermediate
Learners and translate into multiple
languages too when it comes to subtitles
so you can enjoy the courses also uh in
other languages and we also provide
scripts by the way that you can copy and
paste into deep l or Google translate
just in case you don't speak English
that well we're running this campaign
and I'm I'm leaving you the uh the link
here and you can see uh basically what
we're offering we're offering all the
courses um at 50% off it's a great
chance because some of the people can't
afford maybe the price is too high now
we have at 50% and um it's not just
about what you learn in the courses it's
the community I'm really proud of what
we're building because the the value one
of the students sent me a very nice
message and and she told me that the
value in these courses is okay the
information is important but it's a
community you're going to see we have a
specific space on Circle where you can
interact with people um you can ask
question questions you can share your
emotions we have the emotional space of
language learning where people share
their struggles and it's really
important like the emotional part
dealing with uh how do I deal with
failure how do I deal with my emotions
when talking to people how do I deal
with myself as a person in general when
it comes to relating to other people in
my target language how do you cope with
you know not being able to understand
something every each and every one of us
has had their fair share of
disappointments um you know faith
or perceived faders right I couldn't
communicate with that person maybe one
day you feel at the top of the world and
the other day you can't even string a
sentence together because you're too
tired or someone treated you not nicely
and you feel dejected it's the emotional
part that really counts it's a mindset
and and in the school we're building a a
generation of of students who have a
very strong mindset not just the skill
set the skill set is important mind you
it's all about learning how to learn but
it's not only that it's also the
emotional part and the organization
ational part how do you find the time
how do you organize your time your
energy and your concentration and we're
packaged uh everything in um in this um
in these courses and we're building new
ones uh one of the courses that we're
going to build is going to be um well
we're actually already building it right
now how to learn two languages at once
this is one of the most requested
questions you know and finally we're
going to get it out in 2024 anyway and
and I also wanted to share uh the link
for those who cannot afford courses
don't want to buy courses for whatever
reason you can always sign up to the
newsletter and we have um I'm currently
uh selling my ebook but in a few weeks
we're going to send all those who Subs
subscribe to newsletter a new ebook
completely for free and uh it's also an
audiobook read by me I read it in the
recording studio a few days ago it's
it's in the works guys and girls and
it's going to be great anyway so let's
uh I'm going to go to the Bottom now to
see the most recent questions um Love
from India thank you
Janie
um
so Tak FAL I think thank you for
everything I think it's in Danish uh
thank thank you for everything using
chat GPT to generate increasingly
complex sentences in my target language
how do you how to generate the speech in
that language I wouldn't Focus too much
on increasingly complex sentences I
would actually start with the basics and
start using chunks think about that any
sentence is made of smaller chunks not
just words but chunks you know if I say
something like I want to go to Japan
because I've never been there you have I
want to go to Japan because I've never
been there just an example of chunks you
can focus on chunks and then with simple
chunks you can form any sentence I
wouldn't think directly in building more
and more complex sentences I would I
would you can use GPT in this way but I
think it's a better strategy is to think
in terms of chunks not complex sentences
sentences are tools that are not easy to
uh to manage the shorter the better and
when you have short sentences and short
chunks you can uh learn to connect them
and uh in in amazing ways you know
that's a combination of uh the art of
creation is the art of combination my
father used to
say um so let me see have you have you
ever tried to learn Kurdish it's quite
challenging never tried to learn Kurdish
it's not in in my list of languages but
maybe um you know one day it will happen
do you use the IPA symbols to learn a
new language Dakota asks um the answer
is no I don't use the IPA um I wouldn't
go so far as to say I don't recommend it
I had a couple of conversations with
other creators and and and you you know
YouTubers and language Learners who say
oh swear by the IPA you have to use the
IPA never used it if you like it and you
find it useful that's fine I I normally
what I do is I listen and I read listen
and I read a transcript so that I create
this sound it's called sound mapping in
a very natural way my brain picks the
way a language is spoken and the way
it's written puts them together I did
this with Chinese it's amazing even in a
language like Chinese you learn to
recognize the sound and Associate it
with Chinese characters and when you
have languages with Latin alphabet it's
even
better um
uh we
have the logic you ask very in in in
German it asks very philosophical
questions what is what is the message to
the world as you know in general as a
language learner as a polyglot my answer
would be um that I learn languages to
have a better life and you should do too
so learning languages is is something
that can change you it cannot just
change change the way you live you can
get a better job you can get a a partner
you can make more friends you can travel
more easily but it changes you at an
emotional and a spiritual spiritual
level because you start understanding
not only the world better but also
yourself that's that's a message learn
languages guys um every single language
that you learn is one more tool to
understand yourself in the
world uh how to overcome the
intermediate Plateau I've been trying so
hard but feeling stuck Jenny says I
talked about this before um I am not so
for the questions that are similar to
some questions that already replied you
can rewatch uh this video If You Can a
little bit later unfortunately I cannot
answer the same question but to make a
long story short you need deliberate
practice so if you if you go back to the
recording once this has been uploaded on
YouTube you will see that deliberate
practice is a way to um overcome this
intermedia level and there's a specific
reason why you get stuck everybody gets
stuck and you have to learn how to get
unstuck by doing something different and
deliberate we talk about this in the
overcoming the intermediate Plateau
course uh it's all about all the
strategies about how to use podcasts how
to use books um how to use videos how to
read um intensive extensive reading how
to speak and everything in between
deliberate practice and simple
practice anden says once again the
Albanian language is waiting to be learn
from you nice Albanian is very
interesting I have uh one of my friends
who's an interpreter talk about Albanian
he he got he told me that when he was in
Albania and he was learning he was
speaking Albanian people were so nice to
him and I was in Albania loved it loved
the country uh I'd love to be back uh I
love to go back and I'd love to learn
Albanian one thing at a time though the
next one is
Turkish so um someone asks
Globus is I kind of understand uh
Ukrainian because I know polish and and
Russian and I watched recently a TV
series on Netflix I don't remember the
name of it but it was a story of a girl
who works at a hospital as a nurse and
Kev was being bombarded and uh I could
understand most of it because it also
had subtitles so with subtitles in
English I could actually figure out and
and my knowledge of Russian and polish I
could figure out what they were saying
which was an amaz an amazing
feeling um do you set time goals to
reach each level Frank asks and I don't
know if you guys know Scott Adams Scott
Adams is a is a is a famous cartoonist
Dilbert he just wrote he he created this
this series and he talks about goals are
for losers now don't get me wrong he
just says goals are for losers systems
are for winners and I you know that
sentence struck me a lot because I've
been working on systems goals are okay
they give you a Direction but what
really makes you work is systems so
whenever you think about what is my goal
think in terms of systems I talk about
this I think in chapter number two of my
book talk about okay I made the goal of
learning Greek for example in 2017 or
2018 my goal is I wrote 31st of December
201 I think 17 for the next year I want
to speak Greek fluently that's a goal
but how do you transform this into a
system well systems are about habits so
what is the habit for speaking for the
goal of speaking fluently well that is
make sure that you get to speak maybe
twice a week with your tutor every um
every week do you see the difference
between a goal that is vague and a
system the transforms is a is another
synonym for building habits and you can
apply this to any moving part of the
learning
process so um have you tested the latest
GPT conversation feature practice
talking to it I have tinkered and toyed
with it a little bit but I got to tell
you the truth I always get when I when I
think about about it as of now i' I'm
still if I have to think about whether
to dedicate time to talking to a machine
or chatting with a machine and talking
to a human being I prefer talking to a
human being so I very much CH cherish
and prefer talking to my uh tutor in
Greek talking about the specific
language right now uh rather than
chatting in Greek with chat gbt because
speaking with another um person you know
it's not just the the fact that you're
using the language it's the emotional
part and remember that emotions and
skill set they do like this your memory
you know you remember stuff when you are
emotionally involved in a conversation
chatting is not a great way to involve
emotions at least in my book maybe for
you it's
different
um is accent relevant when trying to
become an interpreter mikun Kabuto says
no as long as you speak well enough that
they understand you if you have a
foreign accent is it's not the end of
the world at all I was in this
interpreting School in Paris some some
colleagues were speaking you know with
with a foreign accent it did not matter
what matters is the the the ability to
deliver well to deliver a message well
to translate this message to convey this
message to the audience in the language
you're translating or interpreting
into
um Brian salt marsh the name rings a
bell chauka by the time you get to my
statement I don't know if you're still
there I'll be eating my dinner but
please remind people that learning a
language is a marathon so many people
want results yesterday yes we live in a
world where we want results here now but
language learning is something that
takes months and years so again going
back to what I was saying before about
Scott Adams the cool thing about systems
is that while goal is something that you
set up in maybe three months or four
months and then maybe you get
disappointed a system is something that
gives you a reward every single day
think about that so you it's like
climbing a mountain and you focus
constantly on reaching the peak of the
Mountain Versus focusing on each step
and every 10 steps you look back and you
look at the wonderful uh you know
Panorama as I say time landscape that
you get there and you enjoy the process
that is how it works you get a constant
reward by focusing on the single uh
steps that that will take you there
learning a language well I know that
there's a lot of people on YouTube uh
that say for
example you can you can learn a language
fast but you have to put intensity and a
lot of people in this very um you know
hectic world don't have the time to
learn for hours a day so if you do all
the more power to you as they say but
the the the point is that if you have
one hour you know of time to dedicate to
language learning it's gonna take the
very least nine months 12 months to
start having a conversation and that is
perfectly okay think about a kid kid
starts speaking their own native
language in what three years after three
years of just listening and then start
speaking better and better after five
years and we demand that we speak a
foreign language in a matter of weeks
that's ridiculous if you think about it
so
um let me see here um Helena Helena asks
a specific question about Del liberate
practice in German um how did I learn
German and how did I practice I did the
bidirectional translation method at the
beginning and then I read a lot of books
and listened to a lot of podcasts and
did some deliberate practice also with
friends and tutors so that's that's how
in a nutshell I can't reply with uh you
know details because we're running out
of time we still have I think 20 minutes
to go if you find this interesting I'll
go for 20 more minutes normally it's an
hour um Anna asks what do you think
about some apps like I lost it Lango
talk where you can practice your
speaking with AI I think I already
replied this question if you feel like
if you find it cool and um that's great
just practice with your AI as long as
you also practice with other human
beings
um so uh luuka do you think that
switching in instantaneously between
languages is a different skill from
being able to learn many languages how
we just adjust training it yes it's a
skill in and of itself there's a center
and there's a specific point in the
brain which is called the language
switcher a neurologist that I met at the
conference explained that to me uh now I
don't know the details but yes you can
learn to switch between languages
normally polys can do that naturally but
it's something that you can uh train and
uh like anything else so it's a skill
it's a subskill within the skill of
speaking multiple Lang languages um so
let me
see um Luka hello Luka Roo thanks Luka
I'm not eating just yet but I'm 72 and
still learning I probably have less time
but I keep at it thank you Brian so not
eating yet means that I got to your
question before dinner um many asks Luka
l l is another nice way to say Luka L
I have you ever thought of learning
Norwegian since it's very next very
close close to Swedish and how's it
going with Danish um two interesting
questions no I've never thought of
learning Norwegian just because I speak
Swedish and I have a lot of Norwegian
friends that we communicate in in
Swedish uh I speak Swedish they speak
nor Norwegian I understand and as Danish
I kind of left behind I got to tell you
the truth it's been like two years that
I haven't so much as touched it because
I'm dedicating to other um other
languages something's got to give as
they say someone wrote something chem
French in Turkish uh I just
understood LCA AB I'm not sure maybe
it's high maybe I have and then I'm
gonna start learning Turkish but I can't
answer that question because I do not
speak Turkish maybe someone can
translate that for me
um let me see do you think it's better
to start speaking at the beginning of
the language learning process or can you
learn for a while before you start
speaking I would very much uh wait but
if you feel like you want to start from
the very beginning you can if you have
the drive if the language is very
similar but you don't have to you don't
have to forget to get massive input so
it's up to you but I very much prefer
waiting and getting massive input for at
the very least at very at least six or
nine months before starting to
speak so um what's your approach when
You Face languages with complex syntax
like German excellent question Juan
Tores uh and the answer is I just focus
on chunks so when it comes to languages
that have complex sentences focus on
small parts of the language do not try
to address immediately long sentences or
you're going to go crazy so learn the
basics I want to uh and then you use I
want to learn I want to I must I have to
then you you can use for example an
infinitive I want to learn English and
then you start building upon that it's I
know that this is a very short answer
the the answer would require at least 30
minutes of explanations we don't have
that time but it's a very interesting
question so thank you for for for asking
that um
do you know anything about Tamil I know
it's I don't want to I don't want to say
you know weird stuff but I think that
Tamil is one of the dravidian languages
Southern Southern India I don't know
anything I met Christine Christine is
one of the polyglots she's my friend uh
you probably seen a video of her she got
millions of views where she speaks a
bunch of languages she says m i FBI or
something like that she speaks Tamil I
heard her speak Tamil but I don't I
don't know much about Tamil um Steve
says loved your book look I'm struggling
with motivation and focusing on one
language as I want to learn them all
thank you Steve I am very glad that you
uh that you like the book it's a lot of
people are telling me that they're
loving the book and I love you for
loving the book Thank you um that's why
we're going to translate them into
multiple languages and we're going to
put them on Amazon uh probably within
the next two three months or earlier
than that so you can get a physical copy
I'm struggling with motivation and
focusing on one language is I want to
learn them all that's that's the problem
that we all have we would like to learn
we have to restrict our refrain
ourselves from learning all the
languages in the world because they're
so beautiful but you know something's
got to give so yeah I my my Approach is
to focus on one reach kind of fluency B2
become a language user in that language
and then start learning other languages
so that I can maintain multiple
languages using them in my everyday life
while learning other
languages um what is the last book
you've read um I got to go to the other
room to check I'm I'm reading um I'm
reading two books I think
think one is by Scott Adams uh this is
the book I'm talking about how to fail
at almost everything in still win big um
it's a it's a great book and I read the
previous one how to reframe your mind or
something like that by Scott Adams I'm
reading another one um which is called
son of Hamas this is a story of um you
know this this this guy I got interested
because of this uh what is happening now
in Israel and Palestine so got
interested in geopolitics and I wanted
to understand more of how this whole
thing works and why it's happening so I
got into that and then I'm reading a
book about it's called fundamentals
about astronomy and cosmology I I
normally read three books every day one
in the morning one in the afternoon and
uh one or two at night for 30 minutes a
day reading is like the most together
with language learning is one of the
things I love the
most so uh have you tried to learn
Indonesian neither no I'm sorry I
haven't not yet uh but maybe if I go to
Indonesia I'm gonna fall in love with
Indonesia and I'm going to learn
Indonesian how do you personally choose
which new language to learn I languages
chose me in a way this is an interesting
question I ask myself what what do I
want to do with this language how do I
picture myself speaking this language
and at the end of the day Turkish chose
me I didn't choose Turkish because I've
been hearing about how great turkey is
I've always wanted to go to Turkey I got
to know I have a couple of Turkey
friends always been interested in in in
in tur in turkey and in Turkish and
that's uh that's how I I wait I I you
know I think that languages leave seeds
and crumbs and then I just pick them up
and then there comes a time when I say I
have to learn this language you
know so
um Balan breath um hi Luka have you had
a girlfriend in each of the languages
you've spoken if so how much has it
helped you would you say 10
X um I've had I've had um I've had a few
girlfriends for the languages for the
languages I speak the the the best um in
in I had a couple of American
girlfriends French um you know German
Dutch Russian polish that has helped and
I have to say that the fact that I had a
relationship in like a long long-term
relationship with the with these ladies
wonderful ladies has really helped um
um you know Skyrocket my language skills
because there's two important things to
stress the first one is it's not as easy
as it looks having a partner that speaks
your target language you have to get to
speak that language uh their native
language from the get-go otherwise it's
going to stay like in English and it's
never going to change so that's why when
I started these relationships I always
started them in their language and it it
in and it stayed that way and that
really helped because you not only talk
to your girlfriend but you also get to
know the entire environment the entire
story The Family behind uh behind that
girl and you get to use the language and
you become a language user so that has
has had a huge impact in my language
learning
skills um how do you define your
learning curve with respect to language
acquisition but philosophical and
Technical questions I love that this is
this takes a long time to answer so I'm
going to skip that but keep it for the
next for the next uh uh live because
it's a really interesting question
um what is better to read books or
newspapers where the vocabulary is more
up to dat as stepen crashion would say
everything read books and newspapers the
logic is always an and logic not an or
logic books and newspapers because when
you get to books non-fiction novels and
uh and newspapers and you can rotate
them you know you don't need to read a
book non-fiction novel and a newspaper
every day but you can rotate you can do
all things there's greatness in
diversity and variety and you get to you
get exposed to uh multiple ways in which
the language is used so I would I
recommend all of those which I do I Love
non-fiction novels and newspapers and
magazines and cartoons and as stepen
crash would say anything goes as long as
you
read uh can you recommend a good
resource for learning Thai I got to tell
you the truth I don't I kind of remember
there was banana Thai I think it's
called banana Thai uh because a
colleague of mine used to was learning
thae at the time told me that banana Tha
is a good one I don't speak Thai and I
have never learned Thai though so I
don't know
um uh I don't know so I don't know the
details Turkish chose me is it because
of the beautiful Turkish girls m not
just because of the girls it's because
of the culture uh but I met a couple of
Turkish girls who are super super
nice um so let me see here
um let me
see um
makisa says I want to buy the U but the
only thing I need from the are module 11
and 12 I'm wondering if I should wait
for your new course makist I think I
know your your name say rings a bell
you've been a long time follower if I'm
not wrong and my answer is you can if
you want to if you you can wait but the
OIP the the in general the overcoming
the intermediate Plateau as I said is
not just about the information that you
get it's the whole package it's the
community of Learners you learn to be a
better Learner in general it's not just
about the mirror skill skills you will
see that all the things you say okay I'm
good at reading I'm good at listening
you know you can always find new methods
new strategies that might surprise you
and on top of that these are apart from
the fact you get live access to the
course but you can apply to any other
language but if you want to wait for the
next specific course because we're
building specific courses for speaking
listening writing etc etc you can you
can wait there's no problem Ray Ray
Rodriguez says hi Luka big fan thank you
uh I love big fans question I know you
recommend input via immersion lots of
reading listening and speaking but as a
complete beginner how do you recommend
picking up the initial
words how do you recommend picking up
the initial words I'm not sure what you
understand by um picking up the initial
words my answer is that you don't have
to pick any word at the beginning you
have to understand the like the
structure of the language think about
that language running is structured into
three main phases beginner intermediate
and advanced in the inter in the
beginner phase your infrastructure is
small your linguistic infrastructure the
amount of connections you have in a
brain the amount of words you know the
amount of phrases and sentences is slow
so it's difficult to pick up words focus
on understanding the language
understanding how the grammar the the
sound structure works how vocabulary
works too and then you will start you
will start your brain will start picking
up words better and better goik says
hello my dear friend hi how old are you
for uh in in exactly let me think um 20
days at 17th of December I'm going to
turn
43 Al last we last p padash as they say
in touch um Bak the logic another
technical question do you think the
dynamic repetition helps to absorb
language structure in the starting phase
um yes but I think that as I said at the
beginning in at the beginning of your
language learning process you have to
focus on understanding how the language
works not about dynamic or uh or static
repetition you can repeat if you want to
but I think it's a pointless exercise if
you don't get enough exposure so that
your brain can start figuring out
patterns you've probably noticed that
especially at the beginning you think
that oh I can pick up words you get the
impression that you're learning words
that's fine but my suggestion is you
know snap out this mindset I have to
pick up words and and focus on I have to
understand how this language works
because when you understand the ins and
outs the Dynamics and mechanics of how a
language works then uh learning
vocabulary is going to be a byproduct of
that
and do you use the same methods to learn
Asian and romance languages this is a
very interesting and kind of technical
question the core methods are exactly
the same because the principles to
acquire any language is exact like the
principles are exactly the same but the
tactics there's a difference between
strategy and tactics change so that
basically the strategy is the principles
and the tactics are the kind of methods
in order to address the single moving
parts of any language and every language
has small and well small and big you
know different parts you know Chinese is
has Chinese characters you have to
address that subskill you have to learn
how to address that which is very
specific to Chinese while other
languages do not have that problem while
for example another language like
English has the problem of being a non-
fanatic language so it's really
difficult when it comes to pronunciation
and then you have to learn the subskill
of learning that part of English so the
answer is yes I slightly tweak my let's
say the the tactics but the strategy the
the overall strategy of how I learn
Remains the
Same uh let me see here Globus I got to
say that your tips totally help me my
help my progress in German thank you
Danish B globos I'm really glad to hear
that I'm of any help um fed hi Luka you
speak Greek at a very high level now I
don't know about that but I think I can
have a nice conversation Keda have you
tried to read the gospels in their
original version I'm a huge fan of
Classical Languages hence the question
my answer is no I haven't um I am more
like I love uh you know CL Classical
Languages and Classics uh literature but
my focus is my main focus is to use the
language and enjoy the language in all
its features you know it's in all its
beauty so having conversations reading
books etc etc but I got to tell you the
truth if one day I I get the chance of
reading the gospel in in in Greek I will
be overjoyed but it's not my main focus
now
um uh let me see what's your impression
of US Army language training I don't
know about that I've heard about it I
watched a couple of videos um I would
say that intensity and frequency are big
Big Winners when you have the chance of
practicing or learning from scratch
eight hours a day or 10 hours a day uh
well then of course you can learn a
language fast or faster than anybody
else because you're putting eight hours
a day or 10 hours a day I again I I
don't want to talk about stuff I do not
know but I know that it's kind of a
stressful environment where you are
forced to use the language even when you
don't know much about it I wouldn't I
wouldn't I wouldn't go that way I would
do it in a slightly different way but
the the pr the core principle is
frequency and intensity if you get that
you know we normal people we get to
maybe get to get exposed to any language
for 30 minutes a day 45 an hour even two
hours look looks like there's you know
we're investing a lot of time those
people go to training they're forced to
learn for eight hours a day and I can
guarantee you that if you learn for
eight hours a day then you're going to
get there faster than than us the morals
who's who learn a language for one two
hours a
Daya what's your approach to learning
grammar big question I have a lot of uh
I have a couple of videos or three
videos on YouTube about how to learn
grammar I I if you have the time just
write how to learn grammar L on YouTube
and you're you're GNA see them and also
have in-depth articles about how to
learn grammar uh but my answer is you do
not learn um language from grammar you
learn grammar from language that's my
answer as katoom or LOM you Inver the
name and the surname in in Hungarian the
famous Arian poly used to say and she
was damn right so again at the beginning
when I do this by directional
translation method I basically use only
grammar notes in order to understand the
structure of the language I don't
memorize anything because grammar of
course you have to um you have to speak
a language well you know in Russian
say to speak a language well of course
you have to know the grammar but you
have to absorb the grammar by exposing
yourself to the to the language if your
main focus becomes grammar to the
detriment of actually learning a
language of actually learning the
language and using the language then
things go south as they
say go by go how good is your Hungarian
at the moment I think it's again I I
don't think in terms of levels I think
it's good enough to have meaningful
conversations with native speakers and
um to listen to podcasts I still
struggle when it comes to watching the
news or I'm watching a podcast which is
called fredero podcast really
interesting stuff very long interviews
um I have double subtitles with language
reactor you can watch uh you can watch
any YouTube video with double subtitles
I watch them in Hungarian and in English
if you haven't watched the video I made
a video about how to use language
reactor have double subtitles on Netflix
and on YouTube I understand um 60% of
the content
70% thanks to the subtitles but I still
struggle to um you know understand the
news or things materials for native
speakers but I'm pretty happy with the
level I have with Hungarian and every
time that I get to use it in beautiful
Budapest it's it's a
joy bul and breath you're 43 by the time
you're 83 if I get there do you think
you'll be speaking 30
languages I again I don't I don't count
but I think that if I made it like doing
the math if we have to do the math 40
years from now if I learn one language
every two years I will get there so uh
is remaining the only language you've
abandoned Frank asks very interesting
question actually no because you have
Danish as well and you have Japanese so
there's already three I want to go back
to Romanian and I want to go back to
Japanese and I want to go back to Danish
but you know you only have 24 hours so I
have to decide at the moment what is the
thing that is the priority what what is
what is the priority for me for now it's
learning Turkish learn learning continue
learning Greek Hungarian and and and
resume Serbian so again uh you know I I
want to go back but I have to constantly
every year I have to think you know what
is the most meaningful uh thing for me
given the circumstances I'm living if
for example I meet I don't know I make a
Japanese friend and I get to to go to
Japan well then I will that will
rekindle my desire for learning Japanese
and I'll start again so it really
depends on a number of factors it's not
an easy question to
answer um Ray says in the beginning you
have to learn how the language I lost I
lost that question I kind of remember
how the language Works what do you mean
sentence structure it's sentence
structure syntax it's grammar and it's a
sound structure of the language so it's
vocabulary syntax uh grammar and uh
overall how to all the all the main
parts of of the
language um so um hi Luka big up from
Columbia where's the correct time to
talk my little my little son in English
so when when is it when when is the
correct time to speak to your little to
your little son in English well if you
want you can talk to to him from the
GetGo from the beginning um so it really
depends on I I always recommend to if
you speak English well then talk to your
to your to your kid in English if you
don't speak it that well I would rather
send him to an English speaking school
if you have the chance or have him you
know for example watch cartoons in
English kind of create the environment
where he can get to listen to English
get exposed to English without you
necessarily speaking it you know
speaking to
him thank you co he said that he signed
up for the course and he loves it thank
you very much I'm glad you guys uh like
the courses I'm doing this for you what
really like one one thing that I wanted
to say is that uh apart from the money
of course the money helps us you know
stay afloat and live well but for me it
like the idea of being able to convey my
knowledge to help you learn languages
and to be able to do it across the you
know around the globe is is the most uh
rewarding thing ever because I really
what really drives me compels me uh
makes me stay up at night so to speak is
uh good quality education so high
quality education and I I hope my team
and I were providing that
[Music]
um you asks what is the best place the
most beautiful place you've ever lived
it's a good question um I love it's not
you know it's there's not one I lived in
Paris I lived in in Barcelona um I spent
a lot of time in Berlin I love all of
those cities I gotta tell you the truth
but my favorite place now is K Poland I
always go there for a couple of um
months in the Summer where they don't
have the shka shka is that nice well
nice nice term in Polish it says that
gray skies in Winter I don't go there in
winter but I love it in the
summer uh
so um let me
see I've been living in Poland for five
years speaking of Poland Emmanuel R Ori
working for a corporate company give me
the opportunity to speak in different
languages thank you for sharing Emmanuel
glad to hear you're living in Poland I
don't know where you're living but if
you're living in in in kov kco lucky you
so uh how long have you been learning
Russian uh I started in 200 and um let
me think 2004 uh yes 2004 branka says
nice outfit Luka thank you very
mucha she's
seran
um then I have a question in U uh in
Russian which means are you still
learning Russian and the answer is I'm
using it I'm a language user if you if
you've been listening uh from the very
beginning I'm a language user in Russian
so I get to use Russian get to speak it
watch the news so it's not a matter of
learning anymore sitting down and
learning it's more like enjoying the
language listening to the news um
listening very often to BBC rusi uh and
uh or watch movies Etc so I'm not
technically learning it anymore but I'm
you know I'm I'm still learning by using
it let's let's put it this
way Al
asks
he most fit oh boy so this this is um
like the basically the question is your
preparation as an electronic engineer
that the degree that you got as an
electronic engineer did did it help you
build the rigor that is necessary to
learn uh deeply both the mosfit as well
as the languages mosfit is just you know
it has to do with transistors and the
stuff of electronics um I think that the
degree in electronic engineering and the
scientific background has given me uh
let's say structure so I always build
things in steps I always see everything
as a process as a system that you can
break down in simpler Parts you can
dissect in simpler parts that are easier
to understand and easier to manage so in
that regard um you know the scientific
background that I got is really was and
is still to this day very very helpful
this is what my father used to say he
told me maybe you will not be an
engineer you're pursuing this uh you
know you're getting the a degree as an
electronic engineer and maybe you will
work with languages and actually it it
turned out that way but whatever you're
going to learn at University is going to
be helpful and my dad was right he was
always right he was right most of the
time t for what do you think of Asimo
resources I talk about extensively about
Asim and I always say that Asim is great
so you should start using it as a
beginner
helll asks in French easy Greek I loved
your video with easy
Greek do you think that learning to you
know speaking the fact that you speak
castian Spanish has helped you pronounce
Greek without a doubt it's so resounding
yes because first time I heard some
Greeks speak on the street like you know
on the street and say oh these are drunk
spani Spaniards so always confused you
know I I used to confuse um Greeks with
uh drunk Spaniards uh and and because
the languag is
sound very much alike so yes it really
helped speaking multiple languages if
you know when you have a lot of
languages under your belt you have some
features within some languages that are
very that once you understand them
deeply they will they will help you
understand first and then
replicate um the features of other
languages in the case of Spanish the
let's say the the sound structure is
pretty much the same so vowels and the
melody is very similar so they're really
helped
um makist Luka you should make a video
with Andrea muzi I don't know he's one
of the best memory Champion oh I've
heard about him of all the of all times
I'm sure this will be a fascinating
conversation why not um I'm gonna do one
with Alexandro deini I don't know if you
know him uh I think he's a friend with
Andre mzi and I think I got a book by
Andre mzi if I wrong it's somewhere in
the library but I never got to read
it um let me see
here Ricardo have you ever consider to
make YouTube videos as a digital Nomad
with the amount of language that you
speak it will be original and successful
um I have so much to say about this but
yeah I I spent a lot of time in Rome but
I also spend a lot of time traveling I
should I should do more I don't know if
you guys would like to see me in like in
in real life using languages uh I I do a
lot of videos from home not because it's
I know it can get boring but um I think
I I bought a lot of stuff we can you
cannot see all the equipment I bought
for also shooting videos outside so um I
think I want to take that take it to the
next step and show more of my life here
and more of my life out and
about um so sorry if I'm skipping
questions I see a lot of interesting
questions but we're running out of time
I'm gonna run this this is really
interesting so I'm going to run for 10
more minutes and then we're going to
call it quits as they say thank you for
all the amazing questions I'm getting um
do you believe in collecting
Consciousness yeah I like back that you
you alternate between philosophical very
technical questions um yes there's a lot
to say about that but that's this is not
connecting with uh language learning but
I could talk about hours about for hours
about Collective Consciousness but the
the short answer is
yes have you been learning any Chinese
recently the answer is no um learn some
Far persan Luka I will it's in the it's
in the in the list um n I'm wondering
Luka who's the the most impressive
polygot you've ever met any interesting
story about them um yes I can talk for
hours about Richard simut he was here
four days ago and you know I I speak 15
languages I consider myself an
accomplished polyot a person who speaks
a bunch of languages but Richard is in
another dimension he's in another world
and um I don't think I've ever met
anybody even close to the language
skills the social skills of that that
the Richard possesses so is just out of
this world and uh for all those who
don't know about richer Sim cut just
write Richard Sim cut on Google or on
YouTube and you will see the king of
languages so um how much time do you
spend per day learning a new language I
would say between 30 and 45 minutes when
it depending on depends on the level
when I'm a beginner I I always spend 1
hour and 50 minutes with my B dire
translation so the B Direction and
translation after 10 lessons because
aimal has progressively longer lessons I
get to 1 hour 15 minutes every single
day and um um and U and then when I get
to a low intermediate level I tend to
spend 45 minutes a day more or less
learning new languages then I spend
hours using the other languages that
that I know but that's language user uh
Kingdom it's different it's a different
um matter uh let me see what does not
everyone write in English do we want to
understand each other Lucas speaks in
English uh you can you can ask in any in
any language it's better if you ask it
in English just to keep it consistent
but if you ask in other languages and I
read the the message I will reply in
English and I'll translate for you guys
um let me see a couple of more questions
I'm going to answer there's so many I
can make a video for each question that
you ask it's just amazing um
so if languages determine your strength
would you lose an En cage F to Richard
without a doubt I will lose uh you know
when I have to I don't like comparing I
think everybody's got a different story
Richard is is another is it's it's
another level I cannot even compare
myself with Richard Richard is the man
the king of languages maybe I'm a prince
but not King uh do you also listen to
the famous easy German podcast I made a
video with them and it was really cool
uh with Karina and yanos butth no I
don't listen to easy German right now I
gotta tell you the truth I prefer
watching podcasts like geopolitics and
other things but I'm not I'm not
watching easy German although I highly
recommend it super easy German for
beginners and easy German for
intermediate
Learners um does Richard can Richard uh
Canen Richard reach the level C1 in
three months um I I think I think Frank
the question is not that they're
relevant at the end of the day but he
learns languages fast I think he got to
a very nice level in German when he was
in Germany but I don't think anybody can
reach a C1 level maybe in very very
specific circumstances a C1 no because
reaching C1 means to to add experience
it's not just the skill set it's
experience and you need time for that
and
emotions so when is the advanced C1 or
C2 course coming out we are working on
that but we have the speaking course the
two language course and a very cool I
don't know if anybody is learning
Italian we have something really cool
that has never been done before and I'm
really proud of this Italian course
we're getting out and then we're gonna
we're going to do the the advanced
course which a lot of people in the
academy are asking me because they
completed the first one the second and
now they won the third installment and
we already have the the entire outline
outline of the course but it's going to
take some time because it's going to be
a huge course because from B2 to see1
that's a different matter and I'm going
to put all my experience in it and I
can't wait to get that there what is the
typical day like for you Natalia
interesting question I will make a video
about that unfortunately we don't have
the time to address that but I will show
you uh what I do from From Dusk Till
Dawn as they say uh so you can get to
see what I do when it comes to learning
languages and when it comes to using
languages we're two different two
different
things so
um um let me see Ricardo ask I'm gonna
ask I'm gonna answer three more
questions uh hi is it possible to to
conciliate a routine like yours with
raising children and being married I
don't think so um I I chose this life
this doesn't mean I'm not going to get
married and have children but as of now
I think that the two things don't go to
get you can always squeeze in time but
the way I I live is kind of special
because I married languages so to speak
so it's not easy but you can always
squeeze time to learn languages you can
learn one you don't have to learn 10,000
if you're married and have children you
can always squeeze in 15 30 minutes of
time if you want to it's not a matter of
having time it's a matter of finding
time a cafe and crackle or a beach and
grease both I would say
Bulan um okay two more questions
let me see uh how do you learn similar
languages like Portuguese and Spanish
and not mixing up vocabulary this is in
the one of the answers the main pillars
of of the learning two languages at once
course we're building I would say do not
do not learn two languages at once that
are so similar from the beginning but if
you get one to a B2 level then learning
the other becomes way easier and you
don't confuse it if you're trying to
learn both languages at the same time
and they're very similar oh boy good
luck with that so I would not recommend
it and it's normal that you confuse them
because um you know in your brain the
brain uses certain circuitry so to speak
that is the same for similar languages
and that's why if you're learning two
languages at the same time and they're
both like from scratch then you know
there's some sort of interference that
is
inevitable uh Mara says I'm also very
interested in the c1c2 course hopefully
in 2024 late 2024 because we already
have the the outline but building a
course and this this quality is is going
to take a long time but it's going to be
worth it worth the wait again if you can
sign up to the newsletter we're going to
inform you about all the courses that
are uh coming out and there's one that
is coming out very soon so uh I'm going
to ask the last question what is your
favorite language that you've learned as
I said before uh I love all of them but
I've definitely fallen in love with
Greek the way it sounds the way it is uh
it's a native speaker and I can't wait
to uh do this very long podcast about
language learning on the 7th of December
with Mr Demitri from Easy Greek and then
publish another video on my channel that
we recorded in Greece um and then uh
meet them here they're coming marila and
Demitri in they're coming to Rome and
then I'm G to make a video probably also
on Instagram maybe starting to make some
videos in Greek because I can't wait you
know to use the language not in real
life with uh with my flat m but also to
show you like the beaut of speaking
Creek okay so uh to wrap it up it's been
a a long Marathon I just wanted to
remind you that we have a Black Friday
campaign uh all the courses are at 50%
off and I'm gonna I'm going to send you
two links again for those who are
interested in the in the in the courses
uh as of now you also get uh the book If
you look on the on the
website um the ebook is 15 uh sorry1 19
and it's not just a book so first the
first link is the four courses the
second link is the ebook uh but the
ebook is also an audiobook and it's an
entire course we're presenting it as a
course people are leaving comments you
it's an interactive thing so not just a
simple book it's the entire experience
and I will reply to questions and
there's a lot of people hundreds of
people B the the book and left wonderful
comments and I'm so glad that was able
to put this book together um thank you
Balon I was crying myself I gota confess
when I was recording the last part
because it was very emotional for me for
what I said in the last
chapter um and um last but not least as
I said uh if you're not interested in
the courses you can't afford them or any
or anything in between for whatever
reason um just um let me just write it
here you can
um uh you can uh simply check the
website and you can subscribe to uh you
can simply subscribe to the newsletter
and you will receive a lot of stuff for
free the first thing you're going to
receive is a brand new um we call it
lead magnet which is basically another
ebook it's going to be ready in I think
three weeks so it's it's already it's
it's a book it's like the ebook that I'm
we're currently selling but it's another
I think it's 80 or 90 pages and it's
audiobook so red me in the recording
studio and there's a lot of free content
free advice that you can
enjoy thank you very much uh everybody
um it's been uh it's been great I think
I should do this more often if you are
interested and if you found this uh
useful I hope you found this useful I
always get energized and happy uh
replying to your messages and getting so
many cool uh questions and to to feel
your enthusiasm this is really
refreshing energizing motivating so
we'll do this again and uh thank you
very much again one last thing I wanted
to address if I haven't answer any of
your some of your questions if someone
ask a question I did not ignore it was
just that it's really difficult for me
to speak to think about an answer and at
the same time address every single uh
question of yours keep it there um and
you know if if I did not answer your
question for any reason you can always
ask the next time or you can can send me
a message through the website uh or you
can write a comment on YouTube you can
find a way to write to me and I will get
back to you thank you very much to
anyone to everyone uh you guys are
amazing keep learning languages because
it will change your life and it's
already changing your life thank you
very much have a fantastic weekend um
remember the Black Friday this is a
great chance um to get into a new world
and remember that you always have a
14-day money back guarantee which means
you don't like the course within 14 days
you can ask for a refund and it will be
delivered to you but most people
actually stay with us and they love it
bye and uh as always happy language
Shing
byebye